bonsoir à
tous la séance est
ouverte l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion de la motion de censure
déposée en application de l'article 49
alinéa 3 de la Constitution par Madame
Mathilde Panau et 77 membres de
l'Assemblée la première ministre ayant
engagé la responsabilité du Gouvernement
sur l'adoption en nouvelle lecture de la
deuxème partie du projet de loi de
financement pour la sécurité sociale
pour
2024 la parole est à monsieur Aurélien
saintthoule pour la France insoumise
pour une durée de 10
[Applaudissements]
minutes merci
beaucoup madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les membres du gouvernement
madame la Première ministre collègue 18
fois en 18 mois vous aurez utilisé le
493 et pour la 18e fois ce soir nous
défendons une motion de censure à quoi
bon dites-vous pourquoi déposer une
motion de censure dont l'issue est
presque certaine et bien nous le faisons
par devoir nous accomplissons à cet
instant la promesse faite aux Français
et aux Français de combattre pied à pied
la politique de saccage social et de
destruction écologique que vous menez
nous obéissons à notre conscience nous
défendons les droits du Parlement contre
ceux qui le bafouent et le laissent
bafouer nous tentons de faire naître un
sursaut de conscience au sein d'un
pouvoir législatif qui ne devrait plus
supporter de tout céder à l'exécutif
nous tentons de susciter un sursaut de
conscience parmi vous collègues qui lors
de l'examen des différents textes
budgétaires convaincu que le 493 allait
tout balayer nous disait pour pouvoir
rentrer dans vos foyers inutile de faire
semblant inutile d'amender ces textes
madame la Première ministre vous êtes
obstiné mais nous sommes infatigables
nous voyons bien comment vous comptez
sur la lcitude de notre peuple pour pour
susciter son désintérêts vous pratiquez
un autoritarisme gris fondé sur la
banalité du coup de force vous justifiez
mieux que quiconque le surnom de la 5è
République coup d'état permanent bien
sûr on blâera mes excès de langage après
tout je suis un insoumis et nous n'avons
pas le droit nous à la présomption de
compétence et de modération dont
jouissent par essence les porte-voies de
l'extrême centre laissez-moi pourtant
soumettre quelques questions à la
sagacité de nos concitoyens qu'est-ce
donc qu'un gouvernement dont le premier
et de créer l'ombre complice dans
laquelle il pourra manœuvrer comment
faut-il considérer un gouvernement dont
le garde des saut si l'on en croit la
conviction du procureur général près la
Cour de cassation s'est rendu coupable
du délit de prise illégale d'intérêt
comment faut-il considérer un pouvoir
dont les atteintes aux liberté publiqu
ne peuvent même plus se compter combien
de manifestations interdites sans raison
ni fondement par le ministre de
l'Intérieur et ses préfets combien
d'associations et de contrepouvoirs
visés par des pratiques d'intimidation
et de harcèlement des journalistes de
perquisitionnés des militants traînés
devant les juges et fichés des ONG dont
les financements et l'existence sont
menacés dernièrement on découvre même
que depuis 8 ans le ministère de
l'intérieur dispose des moyens de
procéder à la surveillance automatisée
de tous les Français et ce en
contravention totale avec la loi ce
gouvernement galvaude le mot de
République et en sappe
consciencieusement les bases et pourquoi
s'il vous plaît pourquoi des libéraux
déclarés comme vous trahissent-il si
manifestement la liberté pour accomplir
un projet qui sans cela ne serait pas
toléré par les Français voler aux
pauvres pour donner aux riches diviser
le peuple pour mieux le dépouiller nous
ne le savons que trop nous en avons mis
exemple pour financer la suppression de
l'impôt sur la fortune pour faire encore
grossir le compte des ultra riche il
faut la sueur et l'argent des classes
populaires et de la classe moyenne vous
êtes prêt à détraquer toute la société
pour cela le désastre à l'hôpital public
en témoigne votre réforme des retraites
également elle vole 2 ans de repos aux
salariés de ce pays elle prive le monde
associatif et toute la société de
l'action bienfaisante de milliers de
bénévoles elle va susciter une
augmentation drastique des arrêts
maladies et des accidents du travail
elle va aussi plonger inexorablement
dans le chômage de longue durée des
dizaines de milliers de personnes de
plus de 55 ans en face face à ce
résultat prévisible Monsieur le Maire
répond qu'il n'y a qu'à réduire la durée
d'indemnisation de ces chômeurs et à se
secouer les puces et bien non les
chômeurs ne choisissent pas il y a 14
chômeurs pour un emploi pour voir dans
ce pays collègues représentants du
peuple vous tolérerez ce mépris et cette
injustice pas nous nous sommes écurés
mais nous ne sommes pas surpris nous
savions bien que c'est ainsi que vous
faites baisser le chômage en effaçant
les chômeurs des registres vous avez
fait de même en gonflant le nombre des
apprentis dont pourtant près d'un tiers
ne finiront pas leur apprentissage
tandis que les jeunes formmer en lycée
professionnel eux sont moins de 10 % à
décrocher mais après tout que vous
importe ce ne sont évidemment pas vos
enfants qu'on envoie dans ces filières
vous sacrifiez l'avenir l'inflation
prend à la gorge les ménages le prix de
l'énergie étrangle les petites
entreprises mais vous ne faites rien
bloquer les prix des denrées de première
nécessité augmenter le SMIC indexer les
salaires sur l'inflation vous le refusez
main dans la main avec l'extrême droite
ils parlent de préférence nationale mais
comme vous en réalité ils n'ont en tête
que de protéger les profits des
multinationales des grands groupes des
spécialistes du chantage au chômage et à
la des localisations au fil des ans vous
avez placé tous les CER tous les
services publics dans un cercle vicieux
qui fait souffrir la société toute
entière à force de diminuer les salaires
de réduire le nombre des postes le
personnel fuit la charge de travail
écrase celles et ceux qui restent
impossible de recruter dans ces
conditions l'effondrement menace et les
promesses d'augmentation de salaire ne
trompent personne monsieur hatal a même
fini par avouer augmenter tous les profs
pas question cela n'a jamais été
envisagé le pacte ce sont les miettes
qu'on jette pour apaiser la colère de
ceux qui sont au bord de la rupture
santé transport éducation même stratégie
partout vous utilisez même l'argent
public pour faire prospérer une
concurrence déloyale dans le privé au
service publics appauvr il ne restera
bientôt que les activités qui ne sont
pas rentables et aux actionnaires des
groupes privés l'enrichissement en
garantie en faisant payer tout le reste
aux usagers raquetés c'est insupportable
quand il s'agit de gaver les
actionnaires des sociétés d'autoroute
mais c'est ignoble quand il y va de
garantir à nos parents une fin de vie
digne cette débandade est organisée elle
a des conséquences qui font frémir dans
notre pays la mortalité infantile est en
hausse mesure-t-on ce que cela signifie
à l'instant où je vous parle 2000
enfants au moins sont forcé de se
préparer à passer la nuit dehors c'est
une catastrophe humaine une catastrophe
morale une catastrophe politique
n'avons-nous pas en partage une idée de
la France assez haute pour le dire ceux
dont l'inaction depuis 6 ans permet cela
trahissent chaque jour un peu plus
l'idéal fraternel de la République et la
représentation nationale doit les
congédier la France est abaissée
reléguée parmi les pays qu'onécoute plus
en Europe voici plus d'un mandat que
nous attendions l'interdiction du
glyphosate mais votre inertie politique
est totale sur ce sujet vous vous êtes
abstenu à Bruxelles lors du dernier
conseil on ose y croire la France
n'aurait donc pas d'avis elle dit aux
autres faites comme vous voudrez mais
quel abandon sur la scène internationale
les atermoimements et le double discours
du président de la République
inquièteent jusque dans les rangs des
diplomates ils sont sortis de leur
discrétion coutumière pour le faire
savoir combien de temps aura-t-il fallu
pour faire raisonner un appel au cesser
le feu clair en apportant un soutien
inconditionnel à Israël vous avez laissé
la France n'être qu'un témoin au lieu de
lui faire jouer son rôle de vigilante
gardienne du droit internationale et de
son application rigoureuse vous avez
laissé prospérer l'idée que pour elle on
pouvait souffrir la mort d'inoc pourvu
qu'elle répondit à la mort d'autres
innocents cynisme ou bêti vous affirmez
encore que c'est àin d'éviter l'arrivée
au pouvoir de l'extrême droite que vous
avez adopté ces thèmes ces mots et son
programme vous êtes de ces originaux qui
pour ne pas être mouillés par la pluie
se jette dans la piscine ce gag
malheureusement a des conséquences
funestes j'adresse ici le salut
fraternel de mon groupe et j'ose
l'espérer de toute la représentation
nationale à celles et ceux que les menés
d'apprentis nazis ont menacé ces
derniers jours
et à roman sur ces individus abject
salissent le deuil d'une famille
l'affliction d'un village et de tout un
pays ils doivent être châtiés et
promptement et ceux qui ont jusqu'ici
alimenté leur haine et leur paranoïa qui
dans un amalgame ignobl ont affirmé que
les musulmans de France sont les
soutiens des tueurs du Hamas qu'ils
représentent une 5è colonne ceuxl
doivent d'urgence faire leur
autocritique et offrir leur silence
durable à la concorde civile vous
devriez collègues et membres du
gouvernement R de honte à l'idée de
défendre bientôt devant nous un texte
sur l'immigration inspiré par une
xénophobie et un racisme aussi vulgaire
qu'évident un texte qui postule qu'un
étranger en France est un danger ce
postulat est absurde dépourvu de toute
humanité et il trahit aussi une
conception mesquine de la France dont la
grandeur ne pourrait survivre à la
diversité des origines des usages des
croyances ou des couleurs de celles et
ceux qui l'habitent il faut être
singulièrement timoré et peu républicain
pour ne pas voir que liberté égalité
fraternité ce sont des mots qui parlent
au cœur de tous les humains qu'aucun
relativisme ne les ébranle et que si
nous sommes conséquents et rigoureux
dans leur défense notre pays jouira de
l'attachement de ses citoyens de ceux
qui l'abritent et même du reste de
l'humanité je conclus en m'adressant à
tous nos compatriotes sachez que vous
avez dans cette assemblée des
représentants qui ne se résigne pas qui
n'accepte aucune des fausses évidences
de la mise en concurrence généralisée
des humains qui ne dé Val pas la pente
qui mène à l'extrême droite des insoumis
qui promuvent une toute autre politique
une politique qui préfère répondre aux
besoins de tous que de satisfaire la
cupidité de quelques-uns une politique
humaniste qui affirme que face à la
catastrophe écologique qui s'accélère
nous sommes tous embarqués et que nous
n'en réchapperons pas si nous nous
divisons nous ne parviendrons pas à agir
si nos décisions sont prises par une
poignée d'individus qui ne rendent de
compte à personne si ce n'est aux
puissances d'argent qui les ont installé
nous ne serons pas la France que nous
devons être si nous nous résignons à
vivre sous la férule humiliante du 493
permanentci je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Yannick ner pour le groupe les
républicains pour une durée de 10
minutes merci madame la
présidente madame la Présidente an
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues c'est sans surprise que nous
nous retrouvons ce dimanche soir pour
examiner une motion de censure de plus
suite à madame la Première ministre un
493 de plus pour un PLFSS 2024 si cette
sitation devient usuelle puisque les
Français n'ont pas souhaité vous donner
une majorité dans cet hémicycle je ne
peux vous dire que nous les députés les
républicons souhaitons débattre
davantage au service des Français nous
souhaitons également que vous preniez
davantage en compte les positions que
nous portons et cela dans l'intérêt des
Français car devant avant d'être un
exercice budgétaire le budget de la
Sécurité sociale est le réceptacle des
attentes des inquiétudes et des
espérances de nos compatriotes en terme
de santé le cœur de travail des députés
aurait donc été de relayer davantage les
demandes des acteurs du soin du
médicos-social et des partenaires
sociaux et des Français dans leur
ensemble lors des différentes
discussions générales j'ai été un
certain nombre de points je ne vais pas
y revenir je vais essayer de parler ce
soir davantage des épades et du secteur
médico-social vous le savez trois épades
sur quatre sont déficitaires la
FHF signe un déficit cumulé de 500
million d'euros un déficit et je cite la
FHS qui plonge le secteur dans une
situation budgétaire dégradée de façon
inédite puisque cette dégration est
brutale depuis 2019 avec des facteurs
nous connaissons le covid avec une
baisse d'activité malheureusement des
personnes qui sont décédé à domicile
avant de rentrer en établissement et
puis le segéure avec des sommes non
complètement allouées par le
gouvernement donc un effet ciseau avec
plus de dépenses et moins de recettes et
surtout une inflation avec une énergie
et une alimentation en hausse peut-on
jouer sur le tarif des épades moyennant
les difficultés du pouvoir d'achat quand
on sait que c'est 1000 € le reste à
charge moyen pour une famille qui a une
personne âgée en en éepad on voit la
difficulté le le déficit par lit en épad
est chiffré entre 2000 et 3000 € d'où
les 500 millions d'euros déficit cumulés
depuis 2009 alors faire des économies
sur quoi sur les 50000 postes qui sont
prévus à l'échelon 2027 je crois que ce
n'est pas la volonté non plus du
gouvernement ça fait à peu près 7 se
postes par EPAD et on prend note
également des 100 millions madame la
Première ministre que vous avez souhaité
débloquer c'est un chiffre énorme mais
finalement c'est bien peu par rapport au
96 départements et au milieu au milliers
d'établissements c'est par ailleurs une
mesure ponctuelle alors que ces hausses
d'énergie de salaire sont pérennes on va
vers une situation extrêmement grave
avec une incapacité d'accueil de
nouveaux résidents incapacité de
maintenir les effectifs actuels et
surtout une incapacité d'investissement
pour préparer nos établissements demain
au Baby Boom effectivement la génération
du baby boom née à partir de 45 va avoir
besoin de ces établissements je vous
redonne quelques chiffres en 1940 560000
naissances en 1947
870000 il va falloir donc répondre aux
besoins de 2035 et il ne faut pas
attendre 2000 32 pour dire que nous ne
pourrons pas agir sur ces demandes alors
nous attendons avec beaucoup
d'impatience la loi grand grand âge
pardon qui a été réaffirmé par la
ministre berger je voudrais simplement
pour illustrer cette situation revenir
sur les situations déficitaires
particulièrement importante que j'ai
relevé notamment au sein de de ma
circonscription et au sein de plusieurs
établissements l'établissement l'Eden à
la Côte Saint-André le foyer d'accueil
médicalisé sur les centres épileptiques
à Saint-Étienne de saint-joir ou encore
les les pases belle fontaine qui sont
finalement victime de leur bonne gestion
puisqu'ils n'ont aucun poste vacant au
tableau des emplois ils ont donc un
déficit qui est devenu structurel ils
n'ont donc plus de possibilité d'avoir
de lignes de trésorerie auprès du
secteur bancaire et dans les 3 à 6 mois
ils ne donc pourront donc plus payer les
salaires on est devant une situation
extrêmement grave et et et j'en appelle
effectivement à votre pleine à votre
pleine conscience alors des solutions
parce qu'une fois qu'on décrit une
difficulté des solutions vous avez vu un
certain nombre de maires de la région
Bretagne qui ont proposé effectivement
des financements pour maintenir leurs
épades je l'ai encore vu ce matin dans
la presse locale le dauphinet libéré
dans mon département le le maire de
Voiron maire courageux Julien Paula que
que je cite et que je rends hommage
débloque 480000 € pour améliorer la la
situation de son épan la tourmaline pour
justement ne pas avoir à revoir les
effectifs et maintenir la qualité de
prise en charge des des des résidents
dans cet épad qui grayonne sur la ville
de Voiron et l'ensemble du Voironnais
donc naturellement il faudra financer
ces Haos de rémunération qui sont une
bonne chose dans le cadre du séure 100
millions d'euros sont estimés l'État en
a demandé en a donné 40 quit des 60
millions à à à à trouver les tarifs
effectivement comment jouer sur les
tarifs un moment où l'inflation est la
plus forte et le reste à charge est de
1000 € faut-il réfléchir à un système
assuranciel obligatoire je vous pose la
question et enfin sur la capacité
contributive pour adapter le tarif au
revenus des personnes qui peut être
également une solution en attendant ces
déficits structure structurels pardon
voit des situations locales se dégrader
une perte de confiance vis-à-vis des
directeurs de ces établissements de leur
personnel et surtout une inquiétude des
résidents et de leur famillees pour
revenir sur sur ce point du du PLFSS au
demeurant je voudrais remercier à
nouveau la président de la commission
des affaires sociales madame Parmentier
Lecoq pour avoir fait vivre ce débat et
la rapporteur générale Stéphanie ris qui
a apporté avec patience beaucoup
d'indications précises madame la
Première ministre nous ne conons nous ne
contestons pardon ni votre légitimité ni
votre droit constitutionnel à recourir
au 493 nous regrettons que notre
démocratie parlementaire souffre de
l'instabilité politique que connaît
notre assemblée et notre prays notre
pays et fait le lit des extrêmes tout
cela se révèle donc assez décevant pour
les députés de tous les groupes qui
travaille sur ce PLFSS depuis plusieurs
semaines toutefois parce que vous êtes
vous-même les premiers pris au piège de
cet étau vous voilà obligé de tendre
l'oreille aux oppositions ce qui nous a
permis nous les républicains d'obtenir
des avancées sur un certain nombre de
points je reviendrai sur deux points les
franchises médicales non pas que je ne
sois insensible effectivement à la
responsabilisation et le taux de de
reste à charge un des plus faible
d'Europe mais à l'heure où effectivement
sur un certain nombre de secteurs nous
avons fait très peu d'économie il semble
qu'on moment où le pouvoir d'achat des
Français est en berne et bien de faireun
économie sur leur santé n'est pas des
meilleures solutions et en tout cas
certainement pas le bon calendrier
revenons également sur la gérarco et
leur ponction effectivement il est hors
de question pour pour nous de de payer
par ponction sur laag Carco la
revalorisation des petites retraites qui
je le rappelle avait été obtenu par les
républicains et le présidentoti afin de
protéger le pouvoir d'achat de nos aînés
ces avancées justifient donc toute l'
importance que l'Assemblée nationale et
ses oppositions se saisisse coûte que
coûte des projets de loi du gouvernement
c'est donc pour ceci que je me tourne
vers les dépositaires de la motion de
censure que nous examinons ce soir
actuellement par cette motion vous
exprimez votre mécontentement que le
gouvernement cour circuite l'Assemblée
nationale et de ce point de vue-là vous
avez raison en revanche permettez-moi de
vous rappeler aussi que vous avez été
les mêmes à avoir déposé une motion de
rejet préalable au PLFSS dont la
finalité aurait été exactement la même
qu'un 493 c'est-à-dire enjamber
l'Assemblée nationale sans que nous
puissions se saisir du texte pour
envenir à votre motion de censure de ce
jour si elle était adoptée celle-ci
aurait pour simple conséquence de
remplacer madame borne et son
gouvernement cela ne nous intéresse pas
comme je l'ai déjà dit ce serait une
mascarade qui ne répondrait en rien aux
attentes des Français qui espèrent un
renouveau démocratique et une confiance
restaurée mais au même titre que le 493
la motion censure est un outil mise à la
disposition des des députés et nous ne
contestons pas non plus votre légitimité
à vous en saisir toutefois nous ne
partageons pas cette méthode dans la
mesure où notre conviction reste intacte
à savoir vouloir coûte que coûte
utiliser l'Assemblée nationale à
bonécian au-delà de tout autre
considération afin de défendre nos idées
au service des Français c'est ce qu'ils
attendent de nous je vous
remercie merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur Bruno
milen pour le groupe démocrate pour une
durée de 15
[Applaudissements]
minutes madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues
permettez-moi avant de commencer mon
propos de faire une petite incise
monsieur bon j'aimerais que vous
rappeliez à monsieur saintou qui a
disparu ça prouve le respect qu'il a
pour ses collègues
oui bah c'est pour ça que je m'adresse à
vous monsieur bonpart c'est pour ça que
je m'adresse à vous c'est parce que je
vous ai vu vous étiez là donc voilà donc
je simplement de rappeler à Monsieur
saintoule que monsieur le garde des saau
est présumé innocent puisqu'il l' mis en
cause ce qui n'est pas le cas de votre
leader maximou qui a été condamné
définitivement pour des pour des
violences exercé sur des policiers et
sur un magistrat on voit un peu la bah
oui mais si vous mettez ça dans vos
textes souffrez qu'on y réponde
voilà voilà bref venons-en à ce qui nous
préoccupe ce soir nous voilà donc une
nouvelle fois ici réunis pour débattre
d'une nouvelle motion de censure déposée
par nos collègues de la France insoumise
dans il faut bien le dire l'indifférence
générale pourquoi parce que les Français
ont bien compris que les oppositions
votait systématiquement contre les
textes financiers avant même d'en
connaître le contenu parce que les
Français ont bien compris qu'en contexte
de majorité relative le recours à
l'article 49 alineéa 3 de la
Constitution était indispensable pour
doter notre nation d'un budget et
pouvoir continuer d'engager les réformes
ambitieuses que nous portons pour notre
pays parce que les Français ont bien
compris qu'en l'absence de majorité
alternative et sans bien sûr présager du
vote de mes collègues d'ici quelques
minutes les chances de voir adopt une
mention de censure étaient plus que
limité mais aussi et je tiens à le
souligner parce que vos propres amis ou
ex-amis ou futur ex-amis j'avoue qu'on
sepère un peu dans les méandres de la
nupess rejettent eux-mêmes votre
stratégie de motion de censure
systématique lesquelles sont autant de
défait cuisante pour vous et donc pour
eux cette stratégie et cela vous
surprendra peut-être moi j'y adhère
pleinement et je veux vous remercier de
la mener principalement pour deux
raisons la première c'est qu'elle nous
permet une nouvelle fois d'expliquer
notre projet de le décrire dans le
détail d'en aborder toutes les nuances
et tout le pragmatisme loin très loin
très très loin des positions aussi
dogmatiques qu'ineefficaces que vous
avancez tendance fâcheuse pour la
qualité du débat public que vous
partagez d'ailleurs avec vos collègues
d'extrême droite la seconde c'est
qu'elle nous permet d'avoir un vote sur
le texte en question et donc de montrer
que loin des éléments de langage
caricaturaux que vous n'avez de cesse de
rabâcher le 493 est un outil
démocratique pas le meilleur j'en
conviens mais un outil légal que nous ne
sommes ni les premiers ni les derniers à
utiliser pour aller au-delà du blocage
institutionnel pourquoi je parle de
blocage parce que vous et les autres
oppositions êtes absolument incapable de
proposer un projet alternatif cohérent
pour financer notre sécurité sociale à
ça pour faire des coups et mettre en
difficulté la majorité quel mérite quand
on est en majorité relative d'ailleurs
là pas de problème vous arrivez à vous
mettre d'accord et nous l'avons bien vu
en commission en première lecture on
cherche d'ailleurs toujours l'intérêt
pour les Français de ces manœuvres mais
peu importe vous avez vos belles vidéos
pour les réseaux sociaux au final cela
aboutit à une situation dans laquelle
nos collègues de la nupes arrivent à se
réjouir d'avoir rejeté la création d'un
service de repérage et d'accompagnement
des enfants en situation de handicap
cela abouti à une situation où sous les
applaudissements nos collègues de la
droite empêchent les patients gravement
malades d'avoir plus facilement accès à
des médicaments
innovants bravo mes chers collègues je
pense que vous pouvez être fier de vous
naïvement peut-être nous espérions au
groupe démocrate pouvoir travailler avec
vous en bonne intelligence à la
construction d'un compromis acceptable
pour tous mais une nouvelle fois les
conditions que vous fixez à dessin
rendent impossible cet atterrissage nous
en prenons acte avec regret les Français
eux-mêmes pourront en juger lors des
prochaines échéances
électorales la réalité c'est que
contrairement à ce que vous tentez de
faire croire ce PLFSS se place dans
l'héritage strict de notre système
social qui est autant notre fierté que
l'honneur de notre pays celui qui fait
que l'appartenance à la communauté
nationale va de paire avec le fait de
pouvoir compter sur la collectivité en
cas de maladie ou d'accident ou tout
simplement lorsqu' est venu le temps de
quitter le monde du travail pour
profiter de ces vieux jours ce modèle
social unique nous le préservons dans ce
PLFSS y compris malgré les contraintes
budgétaires qui pèsent sur notre pays
après 50 ans d'endettement y compris
malgré la nécessité que nous avons de
tendre de nouveau vers l'équilibre
budgétaire pour donner quelques exemples
cet impératif de solidarité s'exprime
par la meilleure articulation des droits
à la complémentaire santé solidaire avec
les minimas sociaux comme la loocation
adultte handicapé la loocation
supplémentaire d'invalidité ou celle
destinée aux chômeurs de fin de droit il
s'exprime par la suppression des jours
de carence en cas d'arrêt de travail d à
une interruption médicale de grossesse
il s'exprime par la prise en charge par
la collectivité du renouvellement de la
location prochédent pour mieux
accompagner ceux qui prennent soin d'un
proche malade plusieurs fois au cours de
leur vie nous avons aussi une obligation
de mieux accompagner la santé de nos
concitoyens tout au long de leur vie
c'est le sens de la priorité donnée à la
prévention dans ce texte sur la
vaccination bien sûr mais aussi dans
l'accès aux soins et la détection plus
systématique de certaines maladies les
député démocrate avec Cyril isaac sibil
avait d'autres propositions sur ce sujet
que nous continuerons de dans les
prochains mois la responsabilité
budgétaire celle qui nous pousse à
compenser les nouvelles dépenses par des
mesures d'économie c'est par exemple sur
la consommation et le prix des
médicaments mais également sur les
sommes versées à lunédiic pour tenir
compte des effets des réformes de
l'assurance chômage et de l'amélioration
du marché de l'emploi mais au-delà de
ces deux impératifs ce PLFSS est aussi
un texte d'émancipation qui doit
permettre à chacun d'être acteur de son
destin notamment face à la dégradation
de l'état de santé c'est tout l'objet
des rendez-vous aux âges clés de la vie
que le projet de loi propose de plus
facilement généraliser comme de la prise
en charge inédite des moyens de
contraception notre groupe démocrate a
d'ailleurs pleinement contribué à
renforcer ce texte et s'en félicite même
si et c'est bien normal nous n'y
retrouvons pas tout ce que nous aurions
aimé voir apparaître c'est le jeu de la
construction du compromis au sein d'une
majorité et nous l'acceptons pleinement
sans renier nos conviction nous
continuerons d'essayer de vous
convaincre dans les prochaines semaines
dans l'esprit de coconstruction qui
préside à notre travail commun mais vous
l'aurez compris nous ne soutiendrons pas
cette motion de censure je vous
remercie merci beaucoup mon chers
collègues la parole est à Monsieur
Arthur de la porte pour le groupe
socialiste pour une durée de 10
minutes merci madame la présidente
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers
collègues le dimanche soir certains vont
au théâtre les députés ce soir subissent
un nouveau vaauville ciel
1493 cette réplique iconique aurait bien
pu en effet sortir tout droit d'un
mauvais vaudeville et en ce dimanche
soir de novembre où nous célébrons
tristement
18e de la suite permettez-moi madame la
Première ministre de rappeler à
l'ensemble de nos rares collègu ici
présents d'où vient le vaaueville mais
je sais que vous le savez c'est devenu
au 19e siècle un genre théâtral en vogue
pour Jean-Jacques crousseau c'était une
sorte de chanson à coupl qui roule
ordinairement sur des sujets badins ou
satiriques on fait même remonter
l'origine de ce poème selon la plus
commune opinion par un certains
basselins Foulon de virire en Normandie
et comme pour danser sur ces champs on
s'assemblé dans le Val de virire ils
furent appelés dit-on Vau deevire puis
par corruption Vau de ville alors le Val
de virire dans le calvado dont le
département veut d'ailleurs fermer le
collège du même nom vous en êtes l'élu
madame la Première ministre vous avez
d'ailleurs sans doute lu dans la presse
de vir dernièrement l'histoire vraie et
pas si drôle de Pascal Martin c'est un
médecin elle est relatée dans la voie le
bocage le 27 octobre dernier la
situation est catastrophique nous dit-il
les patients sans solution sont légion
àire Normandie chaque jour il est
sollicité par des malades qui ne savent
plus comment faire c'est pourquoi alors
qu'il a bien le statut de retraité
depuis un mois il ne raccroche pas je
souhaite donner un coup de main mais je
ne veux je ne peux pas tout régler tout
seul comme ses confrères du bocage
etvire Pascal Martin estime que la
situation est très grave les pouvoirs
publics ne font rien le médecin virois
explique qu'il faut des réponses rapides
il faut obliger les jeunes médecins à
exercer pendant un an dans un désert
médical mais je sais que notre député a
voté contre cette proposition le
gouvernement est contre d'ailleurs la
liberté des médecins nous dit-il c'est
bien mais il y a aussi celle de se faire
soigner ce que demande le docteur Martin
la régulation de l'installation des
médecins vous auriez pu profiter de ce
texte pour enfin faire adopter ce que
prône plus de 200 députés issus du
groupe de travail transpartisan initié
par mon collègue socialiste Guillaume
Garo mais voyez-vous deux régulations
nous n'aurons point car le 493 est
arrivé àire comme ailleurs ce n'est
peut-être pas pour rien que le
vaaueville après son heure de gloire est
apparu peu à peu comme une forme
vieillote qui ne satisfait plus le
spectateur en raison de l'usure des
imbogliot cousus de fil blanc ce mauvais
vaaueville ce n'est donc que le
spectacle cousu de fil blanc de votre
mépris du Parlement une pièce à
l'intrigue usée générant de fait une
réelle amertume couplée j'ose le dire à
un certain ennui en raison d'un scénario
mal ficelé et du manque d'ardeur des
principaux protagonistes que vous êtes
nous devrions donc nous contenter de
subir votre intrigue vos intrigues ce
matraquage du Parlement au moment même
où les Françaises et les Français ont
décidé par leur vote de remettre au cœur
de notre système politique en 2022 le
Parlement ce n'est pas simplement
paradoxal ça témoigne d'une triple faute
la brutalité avec laquelle vous employez
à user des et abuser des outils du
parlementarisme rationalisé ce n'est pas
simplement un mépris du débat
démocratique c'est aussi l'une des
causes de la défiance de nos concitoyens
envers leur classe politique nous sommes
responsables devant les électeurs et
vousêtes devant le Parlement mais où est
votre responsabilité madame la Première
ministre quand votre première année et
demi de gouvernement se résumera à
accumuler 493 sans même entendre les
oppositions en débit d'une promesse de
coconstruction vous auriez pu à minima
sauvegarder dans votre texte final les
maigres proposition adopté par les
députés en commission je pense ainsi aux
différentes mesures sur l'évolution de
la fiscalité
ou l'augmentation des taxes sur les
prémix ces boissons alcoolisées
aromatisé un levier parmi d'autres de
l'addiction queenedi ciel le 493 aura
dissipé ses ses
espoirs si nous subissons un nouveau
mais calamiteux votre ville ce soir nous
ne pouvons pas pour autant oublier les
tragédies imposées par votre majorité
allié avec la droite dure depuis juin
2022 alors que la priorité des
Françaises et des Français est leur
porte-monnaie la lutte contre
l'inflation que sur les marchés ou dans
les distributions alimentaires elle il
rencontre la peur de pouvoir remplir
leur cadis au supermarché de faire un
choix le choix entre des loisirs ou se
nourrir le choix entre un repas pour soi
parfois et un repas pour ses enfants
quels ont été vos réformes pour redonner
du pouvoir d'achat et faire en sorte que
le travail paye au nom du prétendu plein
emploi votre formule miracle qui ne
fonctionne pas puisque le chômage est
reparti à la hausse dans une pièce en
trois accles coupable vous avez malmené
ceux qui peinent à joindre dès le bout
d'abord le premier acte ça a été votre
réforme de l'assurance chômage qui a
réduit la durée d'indemnisation des
chômeurs second acte c'est évidemment la
réforme des retraites bien sûr un 493
sur un projet de loi de financement
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale il
fallait oser qui n'est toujours pas
digéré par nos concitoyens malgré les
protestations massives dans les rues
malgré les analyses implacables du
Conseil d'orientation des retraites dont
vous venez de remercier chaleureusement
le président malgré les oppositions
massives au Parlement vous avez créé un
impôt de de années supplémentaires sur
la vie des Françaises et des
Français alors oui même les travailleurs
d'utilité collective Les tucs n'auront
pas la possibilité contrairement à ce
que vous aviez annoncé de bénéficier du
dispositif carrière longue parce que
Madame la premierre ministre votre
Ministre du Travail refuse de considérer
les trimestres comme cotisés mais
seulement assimilés donc je pense ce
soir
auutuciste 3ème acte de cette tragédie
mais pas le dernier malheureusement
c'est celui qui vient de nous arriver
ici avec la réforme du RSA elle va
contribuer à isoler encore plus celles
et ceux qui sont les plus précaires sans
moyens pour l'insertion sans annonce de
trajectoire budgétaire et avec
évidemment l'impossible et fumeuse
promesse des 15 à 20h d'activité cette
réforme entraînera donc dans son sillon
toujours plus de stigmatisation de ceux
qui sont présents comme des assistés
vous auriez pu saisir le projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
pour 2024 ou projet de loi de finance
pour tenter de redresser la barre des
solidarités en luttant contre la
pébilité au travail en augmentant le
point d'indice et le SMIC en abolissant
votre réforme des retraites dont les
effet injustes se font déjà sentir en
tentant de mieux prendre en compte la
qualité de l'emploi alors que notre pays
se classe en Europe parmi ceux où
travailler est le plus dangereux
générateur d'accidents et de mort au
travail mais rien rien vous préférez
plutôt continuer mais votre travail de
SAP votre Ministre de l'économie veut
désormais raboter l'allocation chômage
des
seniors les chôeurs donc les actifs les
pauvres les vieux les cassés les brisés
les mers isolés votre majorité a refusé
la semaine dernière la déconjugalisation
de la location de soutien familial
l'ASF voilà donc votre politique
générale les recrutements de soignants à
l'hôpital ou ce promis dans les épades
qui sont aujourd'hui au bord de la
faillite ça sera pour demain le séure de
la santé pour toutes et tous aussi
pendant ce temps-là le PDG de Carrefour
se gaveff de retenu record et les
caissières resteront elles au SMIC le
dos brisé pendant 2 années
supplémentaires avant la retraite que
dire du reste que dire de toutes les
béances subsistantes dans vos projets
alors que nos hôpitaux craquent que la
pénurie de médicen guette le silence
vous
envahi silence sur la santé mentale
silence sur la santé au travail sur la
santé des femmes les femmes une grande
cause qui pour l'instant ne pourrait
s'apparenter qu'à de la poudre de perle
un Pimpin pour citer notre
président demain lundi nous débuterons
l'examen d'un texte sur l'immigration
qui parachèvera cette démonstration un
texte dont les pires horreur comme la
suppression de l'aide médicale d'État
ont été accepté avec la sagesse
complaisante du gouvernement au Sénat un
texte d'une violence sin nuit madame la
Première ministre vous êtes député du
Calvados vous êtes-vous rendu récemment
à
c'est moins d'une heure de route depuis
virire c'est même 30 minutes depuis
mouchichboville à l'autre extrémité de
votre circonscription allez-vous
affronter la réalité en face que
direz-vous à ces 200 personnes entassé
dans un campement de fortune qui
viennent du Soudan en guerre et pour qui
l'accueil dans notre pays consiste en
deux sanitaires et un point d'eau qui
ont été installés après une décision du
Conseil d'État que dire à ces mineurs
aussi qui sont sous étente dans la nuit
dans le froid sous la pluie que dire à
cette majorité d'hommes qui a fait une
demande d'asile que répondez-vous aussi
à ces femmes à ces enfants qui survivent
dans les rues de camp alors que les
crédits de l'hébergement d'urgence sont
épuisés et que vous refusez de les
augmenter que dites-vous à ces bénévoles
associatifs qui assurent la distribution
de repas pour que ces personnes tout
simplement ne meurent pas de faim
n'est-ce pas vauelin de la frinée qui
disait les Vau dev qui s'entend le bon
temps nous fout encore rire
ici le fond de l'air est mauvais les
temps sont durs et votre vot ville lui
nous fait pleurer pour cela et pour le
reste nous souhaitons que votre
gouvernement soit censuré permet-toi
pour finir de penser que plutôt que fait
d' c'est Shakespeare qu'il faudrait la
scène 4 de l'acte 1 d'Amel qui dit le
mieux ce qui se trame en ce glacial
dimanche soir l'air pince rudement il
fait très froid l'air est mordant et
aigre quelle heure à présent pas loin de
minuit je crois non il est déjà
sonné je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Frédéric Valtou pour le groupe horizon
pour une durée de 10
[Applaudissements]
minutes madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers
collègues encore une fois nous nous
retrouvons face à une posture politique
de collèges de la France a soumise
encore une fois cette posture de la
dénonciation permanente ne propose en
contrepartie rien de constructif ni
d'alternatif encore une fois dans une
démarche à laquelle il ne croit même
plus regardez à quel point ils sont
nombreux ils ne se déplacent même plus
pour la soutenir encore une fois dans
cette démarche il n'y a pas l'esquise
d'une majorité qui soit responsable
cohérente et capable de porter face au
Français un projet différent d'une autre
voilà plus d'une plus d'un an que
l'émotion de censure se suivent et se
ressemblent et que le théâtre exubè des
oppositions a pris en otage le
fonctionnement normal de notre assemblée
sans que vous ayez été capable chers
députés de LFI de démontrer une seule
fois ne serait-ce qu'une seule fois
qu'une majorité alternative à la nôtre
pourrait exister soutenir un
gouvernement gérer notre pays et lui
donner autant de stabilité que nous
faisons à nos institutions vous voulez
nous faire croire qu'une motion de
censure n'est que la conséquence logique
du déclenchement par l'exécutif de
l'article 493 mais si cela était aussi
logique alors vous ne seriez pas les
seuls à signer aussi peu nombreux ce
soir aussi peu nombreux ce soir comme
tous les soirs où sont vos alliés où
sont-ils eux-mêmes ils se lassent de vos
jeux inutiles les 493 ne sont que la
conséquence de l'incapacité des
minorités à rentrer dans une discussion
constructive là en l'occurrence pour
bâtir ce PLFSS car du temps nous en
avons passé sur ce projet de budget nous
en avons passé en commission des
affaires sociales le débat a été réel et
approfondi tous les amendements ont été
examinés et certains même de vos
amendements été adoptés mais construire
ne vous intéresse pas vous plutôt que
cela là vous contentez de répéter la
triste litanie selon laquelle tout irait
mal alors je vous écoute notre système
de santé serait dans un état pire que
catastrophique plus personne ne voudrait
y travailler plus personne ne voudrait
travailler à l'hôpital les lits
fermeraient par dizaines par centaines
par milliers les épades seraient
maltraitants tous la misère règnerait à
tous les étages de l'hôpital de notre
système de santé tout cela est tellement
caricatural que ces incantations ne
deviennent pas vérité parce qu'elles
sont simplement répétées en boucle en
vérité vous adressz un message
d'irresponsabilité aux Français et aux
soignants lorsque vous rejetez d'un
revers demain un budget de la Sécurité
sociale de plus de 640 milliards d'euros
le tiers de notre richesse nationale
c'est un budget qui vise à les protéger
alors pourquoi ne pas dire que depuis le
covid les effectifs à l'hôpital sont
repartis à la hausse pourquoi ne pas
dire que les salaires à l'hôpital ont
augmenté depuis ces dernières années
pourquoi ne pas dire que ces derniers
mois les lit réouvrent à l'hôpital
pourquoi ne pas pourquoi omettre toutes
ces vérités pourquoi ne pas dire aux
Français que notre majorité a augmenté
les dépenses d'assurance maladie de 54
milliards d'euros en 5 ans là où la
gauche s'était contenté de 10 milliards
sur les 5 années précédentes et oui
chaque année depuis 2017 les budgets
importants alloués à la sécurité sociale
permettre la mise en œuvre de mesures
sociales auxquelles les députés de
gauche de l'hémicycle devraient être en
principe attachés ne vous en déplaise
avec ce PLFSS pour 2024 nous pensons
encore une fois les plas et les
blessures causées par le passé nous
devons tenir un discours de vérité aux
Français depuis 2017 pour la première
fois les actes prix ont été en
adéquation avec les engagements du
Président de la République le
Gouvernement investi 19 milliards
d'euros dans l'hôpital alors que
l'investissement hospitalier était tombé
au plus bas entre 2012 et 2017 il était
même à l'os que vouliz que vous vouliez
ou non les chiffres parlent de même
l'état aussi a été au rendez-vous
pendant le covid notamment à travers du
quoi qu'il en coûte et du séure de la
santé 9 milliards d'euros ont été
débloqués ce qui représente une
augmentation de 10 % des salaires nets
sur les fiches de paye de tous les
Hospitaliers cela a été très concret et
continue à l'être donnez-moi donc un
autre secteur qui a bénéficié d'une
telle hausse sans quelques mois alors
certes alors certes alors certes tout
n'a pas été fait le chemin est encore
long pour parvenir à remettre un flot un
système de santé effectivement qui reste
malade et traversé de de nombreux
dysfonctionnements mais je l'ai toujours
dit à cette tribune le recours à
l'article 493 de la Constitution n'est
pas une signicure néanmoins lorsque les
oppositions persistent à vouloir priver
la sécurité sociale de l'un des budgets
les plus ambitieux de ces dernières
années son utilisation est indispensable
pour faire fonctionner le pays et pour
faire fonctionner notre modèle social le
gouvernement a mené un travail minutieux
pour enrichir le texte en reprenant des
amendements de tous les groupes
parlementaires 14 amendements proposés
par le groupe horizon et apparenté ont
été retenue dans la copie finale madame
la Première ministre nous en sommes
pleinement reconnaissants de nombreuses
mesures renforcent la prévention c'est
évidemment une bonne nouvelle je pense
en particulier à la grande campagne de
vaccination contre les infections liées
au papiomirus papiom virirus j'y
arriverai qui sera prise en charge à 100
% dans tous les collèges pour les élèves
de 5e à la gratuité des préservatifs
pour les moins de 26 ans et à la prise
en charge des protections ruell
réutilisable pour les jeunes femmes et
les plus précaires il y a les avancées
et elles sont nombreuses il y a aussi
quelques regrets mais il ne suffisent
pas à tout rejeter ainsi je regrette que
nous soyons pas allés plus loin sur le
sujet du sport santé si l'introduction
par le Sénat d'une expérimentation du
remboursement de la prescription d'une
activité sportive par un médecin pour
les patients en temp de cancer constitue
une première avancée il nous faut être
beaucoup plus audacieux en effet le
sport sur ordonnance c'est la
reconnaissance que le sport joue un rôle
majeur en matière de prévention mais
aussi d'accompagnement pour tous ceux
qui sont sont en rémission ou touché par
les maladies chroniques faire travailler
ensemble les professionnels de santé et
les clubs sportifs pour favoriser cette
pratique c'est autant c'est autant une
manière de faire de la maladie une
opportunité de prendre soin de soi que
de réaliser des économies de santé dans
un moment de rééquilibrage budgétaire en
tension mais notre groupe est lucide et
sérieux nous sommes conscients que ce
PLFSS est un texte qui doit permettre
d'atterrir après les années covid et le
quoi qu'il en coûte qui a permis
d'accompagner les acteurs de santé face
à l'épidémie ainsi que les
établissements face à l'envolet des prix
néanmoins le niveau de dép pens et de
déficit que nous avons connu pendant la
crise n'est pas soutenable dans le dans
la durée faire croire le contraire est
une hérésie c'est pourquoi ce PLFSS pour
2024 s'inscrit pleinement dans une
trajectoire de maîtrise des dépenses
publiques à l'heure où la menace des
déficits est présente et que l'inflation
commence à refluer en dépit d'un
contexte inflationniste persistant nous
ne devons pas oublier pour autant le
besoin de réforme et de transformation
nécessaire à l'adaptation de notre
système aux nouveaux enjeux auxquels il
est confronté l'excellence de ce système
de santé ne peut renaître qu'après
l'application de réformes structurel au
premier rang desquels figure la réforme
du son financement nous devons nous
attaquer au 30 % de dépenses inutiles
que produit notre système de santé qui
ne servent pas l'intérêt général en
santé le sujet est connu il est ancien
il est relativement consensuel et le
président de la République lui-même en
avait fait le constat clair en septembre
2018 ce sont les actes redondants ce
sont les actes inutiles ce sont tout
cela qui produisent des des potentielles
économies par milliards les vraies
économies sont là encore faut-il
maintenant la volonté de s'y attaquer
réellement par ailleurs si le texte
amorce une évolution sur la tarification
à l'activité en réduisant sa part dans
le financement de l'hôpital et en
amplifiant les modes de financement par
dotation sans lien direct avec
l'activité il conviendra sans doute que
les prochains PLFSS soient plus
audacieux en prolongeant et amplifiant
ses réformes pour y parvenir je suis
convaincu que la construction du PLFSS
pour 2025 doit commencer très rapidement
avec l'ensemble des parties prenantes
que ce soit à l'Assemblée nationale ou
au Sénat il nous faut mettre en œuvre et
non pas à quelques semaines de l'examen
du texte une méthode de coconstruction
afin que nous parlementaires de cette
hémicycle les commissaires aux affaires
sociales puissions réfléchir ensemble
aux vraies réponses pour pour moderniser
notre système de sécurité sociale depuis
le début de la législature nous avons su
faire œuvre utile sur des sujets qui
concernent notre système de santé à
l'image de la proposition de loi que
j'ai eu l'honneur de présenter visant à
améliorer l'accès aux soins par
l'engagement territorial des
professionnels ce texte a été adopté en
première lecture à l'Assemblée par le S
et puis par le Sénat et reviendra devant
notre assemblée dans les prochaines
semaines les discussions nourres et
fructueuses avec les députés de tout
bord en amont de la discussion publi ont
permis de dessiner de nombreuses
convergences c'est dans cet état
d'esprit que nous devrions je pense
élaborer ainsi le prochain projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
puis pour puisque péréniser moderniser
notre système de protection sociale ne
peut être l'apanage que d'un seul parti
politique mais chers collègues insoumis
plutôt que de s'opposer par posture et
par plaisir il nous faudra chercher des
compromis des solutions et privilégier
finalement l'intérêt général devant
l'impossibilité de mener débat apaisés
depuis le début de l'examen de ce PLFSS
pour 2024 la voie de responsabilité est
toujours celle de ce gouvernement et de
la majorité à laquelle nous appartenons
c'est pourquoi le groupe horizon et
apparenté vous réaffirme sa confiance
madame la Première ministre et s'oppose
fermement à cette motion de censure
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Benjamin Lucas pour le groupe
écologiste
croyais pas si bien dire Madame la la
présidente madame la Première ministre
Mesdames et Messieurs les les ministres
mes chers collègues mon mon excellent
collègue Arthur de la porte vous évoquez
tout à l'heure le
théâtre j'avoue que moi aussi un
dimanche soir à cette heure-ci je peux
être parfois tenté non amateur seulement
être tenté par une activité plus
culturelle que politique regardez un bon
film par exemple je dis plus culturel
que politique mais je crois que la
politique se niche par part ou presque
c'est donc parfois dans les œuvres que
l'on puise la compréhension de
phénomènes humains ou démocratiques et
je dois dire que j'ai compris ce qu'il
se passait ici en regardant la semaine
dernière un un merveilleux film pardon
voyez j'ai encore des progrs à faire
pour être acteur dans dans la diicction
un merveilleux film d'Henry Verneuil
iomcar datant de 1979 je le vous le
conseille à toutes et à tous je ne veux
pas en dévoiler ici l'intrigue peut-être
que certaines et certains d'entre vous
la la connaissent mais seulement vous
évoquez une une scène qui a agi sur moi
comme un révélateur du du sujet qui est
au au cœur duquel au cœur duquel nous
sommes pardon avec votre usage compulsif
brutal de l'article 49 alinéa 3 au nom
du seul fait qu'il est inscrit dans la
Constitution et que vous avez tout à
fait le droit d'y recourir cette scène
donc c'est la visite du procureur volnet
joué magnifiquement par Yve montant dans
un laboratoire de recherche cette scène
n'est pas le produit mes chers collègues
de la seule imagination du cinéaste elle
donne à voir une une illust dans la
fiction d'une expérience bien réelle
celle du professeur Stanley Milgram je
vous la résume cette expérience un
laboratoire scientifique publie une
annonce un appel à participer à une
expérience sur l'apprentissage dommage
que monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale ne soit pas là on explique que
le but de cette expérience c'est
d'évaluer pardon excusez-moi Mame la
ministre vous avez pas vu donc justement
ça va vous parler d'autant plus donc un
laboratoire scientifique publie une
annonce pour participer à une expérience
sur l'apprentissage on explique que le
but de l'expérience est d'évaluer
l'efficacité de certaines méthodes sur
la mémorisation les participants entrent
dans le laboratoire par groupe de deux
reçu par une équipe de scientifiques en
blouse blanche portant ainsi la marque
de leur autorité à ce moment-là on
effectue un tirage au sort pour répartir
les rôles entre les deux participants
l'un sera l'élève l'autre le professeur
on installe l'élève sur une chaise on la
relie à des électrodes le professeur est
lui placé derrière une console
électrique avec une qui contrôle ses
électrodes avec une liste de de mots à
dictter à l'élève pour qu'il les
retienne l'élève doit les mémoriser il
devra ensuite associer le bon mot à
celui prononcé par le professeur
j'imagine que tout le monde a bien suivi
jusqu'ici à chaque erreur le professeur
aura le devoir de lui envoyer une
décharge électrique légère au départ
puis de plus en plus puissante à chaque
erreur à chaque erreur elle augmente
donc de 15 V allant jusqu'à 450 V au
bout d'un certain nombre d'erreurs donc
de des chararges de plus en plus fortes
le professeur se rend bien compte que
l'élève souffre que le mal infligé est
douloureux l'élève gémit crie et enfin
supplie d'arrêter de mettre un terme à
l'expérience mais le scientifique qui se
tient au côté du professeur lui demande
de continuer et lui interdit
d'interrompre l'expérience c'est le
moment où le sujet professeur commence à
entrer dans un conflit moral il voit
bien que ce qu'il est en train de faire
n'est pas normal il a conscience que le
rôle de la recherche scientifique ne
doit pas être de faire souffrir un
laboratoire scientifique n'est pas censé
être un espace de torture à chaque
hésitation du professeur le scientifique
l'enjoint à poursuivre d'abord en lui
disant veuillez continuer s'il vous
plaît puis en lui disant que
l'expérience exige qu'il continue puis
qu'il est absolument indispensable qu'il
continue et enfin qu' n'a pas le choix
qu'il doit continuer et obéir en réalité
l'expérience de milgam a pour but
d'évaluer le degré d'obéissance d'un
individu à l'autorité à une autorité
perçue comme légitime on révèle à la fin
aux professeurs que le but réel de
l'expérience c'était d'évaluer son degré
d'obéissance à l'autorité et que l'élève
était un acteur jamais soumis aux
électrode ce qui est testé c'est donc la
soumission la soumission étant entendu
comme une action qui va à l'encontre de
la conscience morale de l'individu une
action qui crée un conflit moral
serions-nous madame la Première ministre
nous parlementaires les sujets d'une
expérience 2000 g d'un genre nouveau
visant à évaluer le degré de soumission
de la représentation nationale à une
autorité celle de l'exécutif qui nous
contraindrait a envoyé sur la démocratie
des décharges de plus en plus fortes
jusqu'à la faire s'écrouler mes chers
collègues allons-nous encore longtemps
accepter de laisser faire aveuglément un
pouvoir qui nous laisse même plus
discuter amender voter allons-nous
entendre enfin notre démocratie qui
supplie qu'on la laisse respirer un
Parlement n'est pas censé être un espace
de maltraitance de la démocratie combien
de voltes combien de voltes allons-nous
encore infliger au débat public qui doit
pourtant pleinement vivre dans cet
hémicycle cette fois ce n'est pas un
film c'est la réalité ce n'est pas une
expérience de laboratoire c'est une mise
en pratique dans le réel au cœur du
temple de la démocratie parlementaire
voilà nous nous répétons à chaque motion
de censure des argument j'espère que
peut-être l'appel à la fiction l'appel à
la science à la recherche permettra de
prendre conscience de la réalité de ce
que nous vivons ici et qui n'est ni une
pièce de théâtre ni une fiction ni un
film ni une comédie ni un votre ville
comme vous le mon collègue de la porte
mais je vais terminer mon propos
monsieur le ministre de la justice si
vous pouviez me laisser terminer sans
m'interrompre vous le faites
systématiquement cette fois vous êtes là
la dernière fois vous en étiez empêché
j'aimerais pouvoir terminer mon propos
madame la Présidente serait bon de
rappeler au gouvernement qu'il est ici
l'invité des parlementaires en plus un
dimanche soir c'est quand même plutôt
chaleureux de vous accueillir ici et de
discuter j'ai essayé voyez j'ai presque
fini je n'ai même pas utilisé mes 10
minutes de temps de parole j'ai essayé à
travers l'exemple de l'expérience de
1000g de vous dire que ce qui se joue
c'est la en réalité notre Capac à
démontrer que ce Parlement peut-être
souverain peut-être légitime à pardon
excusez du peu faire la loi en débattre
en discuter et que vos 493 compulsif qui
interviennent sans même que nous n'ayons
pu discuter il paraît même qu'un est en
préparation pour ce soir dès le début
même de la discussion générale qui va
être la nôtre que tout ça épuise notre
démocratie qu'elle suffoque qu'elle vous
invite à un peu de de de raison
d'intelligence collective et de respect
des parlementaires que nous sommes je
vous remercie je vous
remercie la parole à Monsieur Pierre
daréville du groupe Gauche démocrate et
républicaine pour une durée de 10
[Applaudissements]
minutes madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres chers et chers collègues
c'est entendu nous voterons la censure
de votre gouvernement madame la Première
ministre nous le voterons parce que nous
sommes toujours empreint d'une grande
colère parce que la politique que vous
menez est une politique de casse et de
classe une politique de casse des
solidarités des droits du commun euh que
c'est une politique finalement qui
protège qui sert les intérêts d'une
poignée de de puissant des plus riches
de la finance et qui maltraite le monde
du travail et de la et de la création
c'est entendu et le bib le bonheur
intérieur brut est en chute libre dans
notre pays c'est une raison fondamentale
pour nous pour voter contre le budget de
la Sécurité sociale que vous nous
proposez qui n'est absolument pas à la
hauteur de la crise sociale que nous
connaissons qui se développe et des
besoins des enjeux sanitaires et sociaux
vous avez beau parler en milliards pour
impressionner les gens en réalité ce
sont des milliards qui font défaut
ensuite finalement luckyuc est largement
battu euh vous êtes la femme la plus
rapide de l'Ouest vous dégainez le 493
de plus en plus vite évidemment nous ne
pouvons nous satisfaire de cette manière
de faire de cette politique là qui vise
à empêcher le Parlement de discuter et
alors que vous vous attachez à nous
rendre impuissant nous cultivons nous
l'obsession madame la Première ministre
l'obsession d'être utile nous le sommes
utiles dans la Résistance à chaque fois
que nous pouvons arracher un certain
nombre de mesures positives et nous le
sommes aussi dans les propositions et
les idées que nous mettons sur sur la
table pour demain mais je pourrais
dresser un réquisitoire implacable
contre votre politique ça ne serait
absolument pas une prouesse vous en
conviendraz je voudrais rendre utiles
les 10 minutes qui me sont consacrées en
abusant un peu de la gentillesse des
collègues qui m'ont confié la tâche de
les représenter ici ce soir en vous
proposant de convoquer adoc un comité
interministériel concernant les enjeux
de mon territoire si vous le permettez
je voudrais vous parler madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres du Golfe de fosse et de
l'ouest de de l'étant de Berre dans ce
territoire ce magnifique territoire il y
a sans doute le premier port de France
il y
a la plus grande base aérienne du pays
il y a une grande euh zone industrielle
d'Europe c'est un territoire d'équilibre
avec de l'industrie des villes
populaires et avec des zones naturelles
préservées souvent nous avons dû
batailler pour nous faire respecter et
c'est ce que je fais à cette à cet
instant nombre d'infrastructurees qui
nous avaiit été promise au moment où la
zone d'instr industriel au portuaire a
été lancé n'ont pas vu le jour au bout
du compte et nous avons pris beaucoup de
retard notre territoire est un
territoire stratégique pour notre pays
et sans doute au-delà là se joue une
part de la décarbonation de notre
industrie une part de la
réindustrialisation du pays une part de
la transition énergétique écologique et
social avec de nouveaux projets
d'implantation nombreux sur cette zone
et et notre zone industrielle au
portuaire va donc connaître un second
souffle notre territoire va Sanger c'est
une belle aventure qui peut s'ouvrir à
celles et ceux qui vivent et travaille
sur notre territoire dans ce coin de de
Provence à condition qu'ils en soient
qu'elles en soient partie prenante et ne
soient pas contraint d'en payer le prix
mais pour l'instant la puissance
politique et je dois dire l'état ne sont
pas au rendez-vous voilà de long mois
que je frappe à toutes les portes d'un
certain nombre de ministères de grandes
administrations de grandes entreprise
pour faire entendre cette voix et je
profite donc madame la Première ministre
que nous soyons ici réunis je prends
d'autant plus les devant que j'ai oui
dire qu'il y allait avoir un un conseil
interministériel à dunkerer concernant
les enjeux d'unkererqui et je me permets
donc d'utiliser ce moment pour vous
parler de ce qui se passe chez moi
monsieur le ministre de l'Industrie les
entreprises déjà installées sont en
train peu à peu de modifier leur process
et c'est une bonne chose il faut
accélérer le mouvement de ce point de
vue- làà et je veux dire l'extrême
vigilance à avoir à l'égard des
mouvement de capitaux et je pense
particulièrement à une entreprise
entreprise ascétal je suis un peu
préoccupé par ce qui se profile en tout
cas vigilant et donc je voulais le
souligner au passage vigilant et
également à l'égard de l'utilisation de
l'argent public qui doit vraiment servir
une stratégie de transition et nous
permettre de gagner en maîtrise publique
j'ajoute à cela la nécessité de de
planifier de mieux organiser également
l'économie circulaire où sur notre zone
il y a un certain nombre de possibilités
qui ne sont pas exploité et pourquoi pas
un incubateur industriel avec de la
recherche pour que nous puissions avoir
une capacité d'expertise augmentée
publique permettant d'agir sur la
transformation de l'industrie l'un des
plus grands défis madame la Première
ministre est celui des transports notre
grand port toujours en croissance est
relié au réseau ferré par une voie de
chemin de fer et par à la route par une
route départementale nous sommes
largement en dessous déjà aujourd'hui de
ce que notre port aurait besoin pour
pour faire face nous avons besoin donc
d'investir dans le ferroviaire pour le
fret pour les voyageurs pour les
habitantes et les habitants de nos
villes pour celles et ceux qui
travaillent et cette revendication est
incontournable pour relever le défi
climatique et le défi du quotidien et
pour l'instant je dois dire que je ne
vois rien venir il faut que des choses
se dégagent rapidement et les
infrastructures routières également sont
déjà saturées avec une mise en danger du
point de vue de la sécurité et de la
santé pour les populations et j'espère
que le contournement de Martigue et de
port de Bou ne sera pas une nouvelle
fois repoussé ça fait des décennies que
ça dure sur l'ensemble de ces enjeux il
faut un plan global intégrant y compris
le fluvial autre défi celui de
l'électricité madame la ministre de la
transition énergétique c'est un sujet
sur lequel il y a des choses qui sont
lancées il faut il faut le dire et avec
une vigilance particulière à avoir avec
y compris une augmentation des besoins
domestiques et également évidemment avec
tout ce que je viens d'indiquer une
augmentation des besoins du point de vue
industriel et aussi du point de vue des
transports le 4è défi monsieur le
ministre du Travail c'est celui de la
formation professionnelle pour affronter
tout cela il y aura besoin de former
massivement un certain nombre de femmes
et d'hommes de jeunes nous avons réussi
à préserver des outils je pense au
centre AFPA qui était menacé de
fermeture il faut maintenant lui donner
les moyens d'aller de l'avant et
déployer une stratégie offensive pour
construire des réponses en matière de
formation professionnelle qualifiante et
répondre au aux besoins de formation
NOTAM ment dans le cadre de cette
transition que je suis en train
d'évoquer il y a aussi d'autres métiers
il faut pas se concentrer que là-dessus
il y a une filière cinéma chez nous et
voilà il faut également aider à
sécuriser l'emploi et les parcours et
travaill sur les métiers c'est un enjeu
décisif pour cela Madame la Ministre de
la des lycées professionnels je crois
qu'il ne faut pas affaiblir l'offre de
formation en la matière et puis il faut
aussi renforcer madame la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur les formations
d'enseignement supérieur dans notre
territoire nous sommes sousdotés il va y
en avoir besoin mais avoir besoin de
métiers très différents l'enjeu
environnemental appelle aussi en soi des
investissements monsieur le ministre de
l'Environnement la protection de la
forêts des étanss de la mer de l'air je
demande madame la ministre de la Santé
environnementale je Demandre et je vous
en ai fait part depuis très longtemps
que nous soyons territoire pilote dans
la lutte contre les pollutions
atmosphériques j'espère que cette idée
va pouvoir prospérer et je voudrais
insister sur les investissements massifs
nécessaire pour mieux protéger notre
étant de B et faire un autre usage de
l'eau qui arrive par euh la chaîne
hydroélectrique durant ce Verdon il y a
de grands investissements qui peuvent
être utiles et rentrer en synergie avec
tout cela nous ne pourrons pas investir
simplement dans le développement
industriel il faut investir aussi pour
la nature et pour notre environnement
sur la base des travaux que nous avons
fait avec Jean-Marc zulési et Éric Diar
je veux insister madame la ministre des
collectivités territoriales sur la
nécessité de donner aux communes
notamment les moyens de faire face à ces
transformations et de pouvoir déployer
les infrastructures et les services
publics je pense particulièrement à la
question du logement public sur lequelle
il y a une tension considérable pour
faire face aux enjeux de transformation
de ce territoire à quoi il faut ajouter
aussi la mise à niveau des services de
l'État et je dois dire que déjà nous ne
sommes pas au niveau nécessaire je pense
aux douanes je pense à la police
nationale je pense à l'inspection du
travail aux inspecteurs inspectrices des
installations classées et cetera la
liste pourrait être longue évidemment
comment ne pas parler de l'éducation
nationale enfin comment imaginer que
l'hôpital de martig monsieur le ministre
nous en avons parlé qui n'est pas situé
sur la zone par hasard ne voit pas ces
projets de rénovation pleinement
soutenus et nous ne sommes pas au niveau
à ce stade sa capacité de soins doit
être développée son offre de soins doit
être développée ça appelle un
investissement dans l'humain comme dans
tous les hôpitaux de notre territoire
mais aussi dans les infrastructures pour
que nous soyons véritablement capable de
faire face à l'avenir à ce qui est en
train d'arriver je crois madame la
Première ministre qu'il n'existe encore
que des visions trop parcéisées de ce
qui est en train de se passer que cela
fragilise les perspectives l'idée d'une
opération d'intérêt national sans
établissement public et sur la table il
faut l'étudier comme celle d'un contrat
de projet partenariat d'aménagement et
ce que je mets en débat c'est un plan
d'investissement territorial
exceptionnel qui soit adapté aux
mutations à caractère stratégique
national auquel notre territoire est
confronté car c'est bien de cela dont il
s'agit nous ne voulons pas subir les
transformations qui doivent permettre à
notre pays de mieux affronter les défis
contemporains moi encore en être victime
nous voulons en être actrice et acteur
les décider les accompagner nous voulons
qu'elle nous permette de vivre mieux et
de vivre bien de tout cela je n'aurais
jamais pu parler dans la séquence
budgétaire ça dépense d'ailleurs
largement le cadre d'un budget ça montre
le besoin de d'action publique et c'est
pourquoi je veux donner l'impulsion et
je vous tends la main madame la Première
ministre s'il y a moyen d'avancer mais
il n'y a pas d'ambiguïté de l'autre main
je voterai la censure je la voterai quoi
qu'il en soit naturellement et si vous
me le permettez madame la Présidente la
séance du comité interministériel et le
l je vous remercie monsieur le député la
parole est à Madame Estelle Youssoufa
pour le groupe Liot pour une durée de 10
minutes madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres chers collègues notre
démocratie est malade c'est le constat
qui s'impose et je déplore votre
incapacité à trouver des consensus sur
des enjeux aussi importants que ce lié à
la santé de nos compatriotes c'est le
constat qui s'impose lorsque nous lisons
que le Président de la République tense
les partenaires sociaux patronas et
syndicats pour quelle raison ils ont eu
le malheur de se mettre d'accord sur la
le régime de retraite complémentaire à J
Carco au nom de notre attachement au
paritarisme cœur de notre modèle social
nous vous avons dit notre résolution à
lutter contre la ponction de laag Carco
que vous envisagiez pour financer le
déficit du régime général de
retraite si nous ne voterons pas la
motion de censure c'est parce que nous
avons renoncé parce que vous avez
renoncé à cette ponction unilatérale et
injuste c'est aussi parce que vous avez
renoncé à une autre mesure injuste votre
projet d'augmenter la franchise sur les
médicaments et la participation
forpétaire pour les consultations pour
autant ne pas cette motion de censure ne
signifie pas que nous vous accordons
notre confiance ni que nous vous
encourageons à cette accumulation de
493 je vous retourne les mots du
président de la République aux
partenaires sociaux madame la Première
ministre réveillez-vous car notre
démocratie est malade notre système de
santé est lui à bout de souffle nous
connaissons tous l'engorgement de nos
hôpitaux ces derniers jours c'est
l'épidémie de bronchiolly qui débordent
de les services d'urgenence pédiatrique
les Français nous disent aussi leur
difficultés à trou trouver un médecin
traitant et nous voyons les déserts
médicaux s'étendre malgré les mesures
que vous prenez malgré les numérus
apertus ces déserts
s'étendent la situation est dégradée
mais elle est encore plus dans les
territoires ultramarins et à maotte que
je représente ici la situation n'est pas
rouge elle est
cramoisie vous savez tous la crise de
l'eau qui fait basculer maotte mais
l'autre crise qui nous accable est celle
de l'effondrement de notre seul
hôpital le centre hospitalier de Mayotte
subit depuis un an une hémorragie de
médecins sur fond de règlement de contre
entre la direction et les paatticiens
les médecins ont appelé l'administration
et les inspections au secours en
dénonçant l'insécurité pour les patients
avec un nombre d'événements indésirable
alarmant c'est le jargon administratif
pour dire que les malades à Mayotte sont
en danger parce que les urgences sont
quasiment sans médecins dans un tel état
de désorganisation que les soignants qui
sont encore en poste redoute de
commettre de la maltraitance médicale et
c'est
gravissime actuellement le service des
urgences de mayott ne compte que 6
médecins titulaires sur les 37 postes
offerts 6 sur 37 faute d'encadrement les
urgences de Mayotte ont perdu leur
agrément pour accueillir les internes
océan indiens et lancé le recrutement de
trois faisants fonction d'interne venu
de Madagascar et des Comores
c'est-à-dire que Mayot est en train
actuellement de dépouiller ces pauvres
voisins des quelques médecins en
formation pour compenser la guerre des
égos du CHM et faire avancer du même
coup le projet de sortie totale de la
santé de Mayotte du système national
c'est-à-dire que Mayotte dépouille ses
pauvres voisins de ces quelques médecins
et les patients étrangers vous continuez
d'affluer à Mayotte et alimenter ainsi
l'effondrement de notre Magre système de
santé totalement
asphyxié parce qu'à Mayotte impatient
sur sur de dans notre hôpital est
étranger par dérogation le patient
étranger ne cotise ni ne pie pour ses
soins à maotte par dérogation il n'y a
pas d'aide médicale d'État à Mayotte ni
de CMU à Mayotte c'est-à-dire que l'État
a fait le choix de garder pour la santé
des étrangers 50 centimes de chaque euro
dépensé dans notre hôpital à maotte
c'est une aberration et un combat que je
mènerai dans le cadre de du projet de
loi
immigration parce que cette pseudo
générosité se fait au dépend de la santé
des maoraais purement et simplement et
c'est une générosité à minima puisque
les dépenses de santé s'élèvent à 418
millions d'euros par an à maotte alors
que nous sommes en réalité au moins
450000 habitants l'état investit donc
929 € par habitant pour la santé à
maotte contre
3475 € par habitant dans l'Hexagone
c'est-à-dire trois fois moins
et le mode de financement du CHM doit
être revu notre deuxième hôpital enfin
de sortir de terre on nous dit que
l'État ne veut pas alimenter d'appel
d'air à Mayotte parlons-en parce que je
crois madame la Première ministre que
l'État fait des économies sur la santé
des Maoris en se cachant derrière cette
hypocrisie la moitié des prestations
sociales n'existent pas à maotte
lorsqu'elles existe leur montant
n'atteint que la moitié du niveau
national ni le code de la sécurité ni le
code du travail ne sont appliqué sur
notre île les retraites sont indigentes
parce que l'État plafonene et refuse que
les Maora puissent effectivement cotiser
normalement mais l'état rend par contre
gratuit les soins aux étrangers
l'accouchement est gratuit à maotte pour
les étrangères par
dérogation vous créez donc l'appel d'air
pour mieux justifier de sacrifier les
maahorais et nourrir notre exode médical
et social nous Maorais de vont quitter
notre île pour nous soigner et
bénéficier de nos droits sociaux lors du
comité interministériel outremè cette
semaine nous avons demandé une
convergence des droits pour Mayotte dès
2026 nous à Mayotte sommes français
depuis
1841 nous sommes département depuis
2012 ça suffit l'égalité c'est
maintenant pas demain pas avant-hier pas
dans 10 ans pas dans aucune date
maintenant
j'ai protesté auprès de votre
gouvernement mais aussi de la présidence
de la République sur la question du Plan
Régional de Santé commis par votre
ARS alors que notre île fait face à un
défi démographique hors du commun les
autorités de santé à Mayot ne présentent
aucune politique de limitation des
naissances pas de planning familial ni
de plan massif d'éducation sexuelle ou
de sensibilisation aux violences
sexuelles il est important pour moi de
dénoncer la logique de de santé publique
qui préside à ce PRS pour Mayotte notre
santé passe nécessairement par l'île de
la Réunion à 1500 km la logique des
évacuations sanitaires est une
aberration pour la santé des maoraaises
et des Maoris c'est aussi un coût
explosif pour la dépense publique
comprenez que pour un patient Maoré une
évacuation sanitaire signifie un
transfert en ambulance de l'hôpital puis
en bateau puis un autre transfert en
ambulance avant de prendre l'avion
pendant 2hes et d'être à nouveau
transféré en ambulance c'est autant de
prise que de risques médicaux cela prend
en moyenne 8 he ce sont des opérations
de transfert qui sont des risques pour
les patients et cette Logère et cette
logique opère depuis des années sur la
santé des maorés alors que les experts
répètent que l'éloignement des patients
de leur famille mais aussi la distance
loin de leur environnement familiieux
diminue leurs Chan lors des traitements
la logique de déploiement régional de la
santé se fait au détriment des Maorais
et tous les investissements pour les
plateaux techniques de qualité et les
projets des projets médicaux se font
hors de notre île je veux aussi vous
dire que depuis le début de mon mandat
je n'ai de cesse de demander au recteurs
successif au président de l'université
locale mais aussi au directeurs de l'ARS
et au directeurs de l'hôpital de
développer les filières de formation des
médecins à Mayotte pour que les jeunes
maahorés qui le souhaitent puissent un
jour soigner la
mais rien n'est fait pour que les
filières pass puissent être débloqué et
créé à Mayotte avec des places bloquées
pour les patients maahoris les étudiants
maahorais parce que nous savons que la
poussée démographique de Mayotte n'est
pas qu'une mauvaise nouvelle il y a
parmi tous nos jeunes statistiquement
nécessairement les médecins de demain la
décision poussée par le ministère de
l'enseignement supérieur de construire
un statut dérogatoire pour le centre
universaire universitaire de demny gur
mal des ambitions de l'État à maotte
pour l'avenir de notre île il est
impossible de construire un avenir sans
nos enfants sans nos cerveaux sans une
éducation supérieure de qualité et
l'obsession de l'État pour les écoles
primaires les collèges et les lycées
masque mal l'absence totale d'ambition
pour les formations professionnelles
l'enseignement universitaire les
partenariats internationaux qui
permettront à nos jeunes de Mayotte de
devenir les cadres de demain les
médecins des hôpitaux de Mayotte les
ingénieurs de la manne pétrro et gazière
du canal du
Mozambique à aucun moment nos
interlocuteurs au niveau de l'État à
Mayotte ne semblent envisager
l'excellence la réussite ou l'ambition
de notre territoire pour un avenir
meilleur nous sommes à maotte
visiblement condamnés à la médiocrité
condamné à rester la succursale de
l'immigration comorienne pour
l'éducation l'éducation comorienne la
santé comorienne quiexige des immigrants
clandestins qui arrivent quotidiennement
par
bateau nous vous attendons madame la
première ministre dans les prochains
jours à Mayotte nous espérons que vous
aurez des promesses et surtout des
résultats concrets pour notre île je
vous
remercie merci beaucoup ma cher
collègues la parole est à Monsieur
Emmanuel pèlerin pour le groupe
Renaissance ça ça monte c'est génial
j'adore ce truc
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues docin
considère que la folie consiste à faire
alassablement la même chose tout en
espérant obtenir un résultat
différent collègu de la France insoumise
vous conviendrez que l'exercice auquel
nous nous prêtons une nouvelle fois
aujourd'hui leur donne raison je vous le
demande avec le dernier degré de
sincérité dont je peux faire preuve quel
est l'objectif de cette anè motion de
censure n'avez-vous pas vous-même oublié
le sens de cette opposition permanente
et caricaturale que vous nous servez
depuis le début de la
législature je suis au regret de vous le
dire mais les mêmes causes produiront
systématiquement les mêmes effets une
fois de plus vous ne parviendrez pas à
renverser le gouvernement
une issue heureuse car quand bien même
cette motion serait adoptée que
feriez-vous
ensuite vous refusez de former une
majorité alternative avec le
rassemblement national cela vous honore
mais tout respectable soit-elle cette
décision vous interdit par la même
occasion d'obtenir les moyens de vos
ambitions pour le dire plus simplement
vous êtes
coincé coincé et dépourvu sinon du bruit
de la fureur
du tumulte et du fracas ces mots d'ordre
qui peineent à quitter vos esprits
malgré l'absence en ces lieux de celui
qui les y a
placé cette situation est en vérité fort
regrettable car il ne tient qu'à vous de
sortir de cette ornière où vous
maintiennees vos propres dogmes vos
futurs expartenaires de laanupes l'ont
bien compris au point qu'il ne
s'interdisent plus de voter en faveur de
mesures dont ils savent qu'elles sont
bénéfiques pour les Françaises et les
Français
l'exemple plus récent qui me vient à
l'esprit concerne la proposition de loi
portant mesures pour bâtir la société du
Bien vieillir en France que nous avons
adopté jeudi dernier avec le soutien des
groupes socialistes et
écologiste initialement animé d'une
hostilité ouverte et franche vis-à-vis
du texte les discussions et les
engagement pris de manière consensuelle
tant avec la majorité qu'avec le
gouvernement ont eu raison
de leur réticence
première une victoire
incontestablement mais une victoire pour
nos aînés et pour celles et ceux qui
s'occupent d'eux au quotidien cette
victoire vous auriez pu en être acteur
mais une fois de plus vous avez préféré
vous opposer par principe à des mesures
que nous n'en doutons pas vous approuve
en votre fort
intérieur ne craignons pas les mots
collègues insoumis il y a quelque chose
de profondément puérile dans le fait de
concevoir l'exercice de votre mandat à
l'ône du conflit permanent lentement
mais sûrement vos alliés vous feront
défaut car ils savent que cette posture
est incompatible avec les intérêts des
Françaises et des
Français mais venons-en au terme de
votre motion de censure puisqu'il vous
plaît de nous réunir à nooséam pour
discuter de vos remontrances celle-ci
débute par l'une de ces contradictions
auxquelles vous nous avez désormais
habitué d'une part vous indiquez que les
parlementaires n'ont pas su pas pu se
prononcer sur le budget de la Sécurité
sociale puis d'autre part vous
fanfaronné sur le rejet du PLFSS en
commission des affaires sociales le 20
octobre
dernier ce que vous omettez de rappeler
c'est que ce même P FSS pour 2024 a été
adopté et largement adopté en commission
mercredi dernier tout comme la première
partie du texte ce jeudi cette fois ici
même dans dans cet hémicycle à date et
jusqu'à preuve du contraire les députés
se sont bel et bien prononcés sur le
budget de la sécurité social et ne vous
en déplaise ils l'ont
approuvé le paragraphe suivant
interpelle encore plus dans celui-ci
vous regrettez le rétablissement
approuvé par la commission des affaires
sociales de notre assemblée de
dispositions supprimé ou altéré par le
Sénat comment comprendre que vous
émouviez du retour de la réforme du
prélèvement social des
micro-entrepreneurs et des plateformes
collègu tout comme nous vous avez à cœur
les droits des travailleurs et pourtant
vous opposeriez à une mesure qui
permettrait de s'assurer qu'ils
bénéficieront bien de leurs droits
sociaux c'est
incompréhensible comment comprendre que
vous émouviez d'un hypothétique
prélèvement sur sur l'excédent de
recettes généré par la réforme des
retraites pour l'asir cargo collègu tout
comme nous vous avez à cœur le niveau de
vie des traité les plus modestes et
pourtant vous opposeriez un prélèvement
qui s'il devait advenir permettrait de
revaloriser les petite pension du régime
général c'est encore
incompréhensible comment comprendre que
vous émouviez d'un rétablissement de
longondam pour
2024 collègue tout comme nous vous avez
à cœur la santé des Françaises et des
Français et pourtant vous vous
opposeriez à ce que près de 250
milliards soi employés à afin de
préserver celle-ci c'est encore
incompréhensible tout ceci n'est que
posture de votre part mais il convient
que celles et ceux qui suivent nos
débats le sache le rejet du projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale aurait pour conséquence pure et
simple de paralyser la solidarité
nationale malad famille travailleurs
personnes en situation de handicap
retraité toutes et tous se
retrouveraient seul face aux épreuves de
la vie et
pourquoi parce que des parlementaires
d'opposition auront sacrifié leurs
intérêts sur l'tel des basses manœuvre
politiciennees tant que nous serons
responsabilités jamais nous ne
laisserons pareil chose à devenir le
groupe Renaissance ne votera évidemment
pas cette motion de
senscir mais il redit encore et redira
autant qu'il le faudra son plein et
entier soutien au gouvernement de madame
ellabeth borne merci merci beaucoup mon
cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Philippe Ballard pour le rassemblement
national oui merci je veux bien j'ai un
chat dans
ma madame la présidente Madame la
première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres chers collègues je vais
commencer mon intervention par Ben la
conclusion le groupe rassemblement
national ne votera pas cette motion de
censure alors du coup comme il me reste
un petit peu de temps je vais vous dire
pourquoi je vais essayer de développer
quand même en fait laanupè et
particulièrement la la France insoumise
c'est un petit peu comme le gouvernement
vous abîmez la démocratie vous
désacralisez la politique pourquoi
déposer une 17e 18e on sait même plus
d'ailleurs motion de censure vous savez
très bien qu'elle n'a mais alors
strictement aucune chance d'aboutir
aucune alors quelle est la raison c'est
pour avoir le le plaisir de se retrouver
un dimanche soir tous ensemble dans
l'hémicycle ou c'est pour vos réseaux
sociaux moi je penseche plutôt pour la
la deuxième
solution une petite remarque au passage
seule la France insoumise l'a signé
cette motion mais qu'est-ce qui se passe
au sein de l'anupes qu'est-ce qui se
passe s'affaiblit c'est plus que c'était
quand même hein euh laanupes là non
franchement chers collègues comme aurait
dit mais Jaquet musclez votre jeu là
muscer votre jeu bon enfin c dit vous le
faites suffisamment souvent bon ça
franchement c'est pas sérieux alors
quant au gouvernement 18e 493 alors
qu'est-ce que vous recherchez en fait
alors c'est peut-être à rentrer dans le
Guinness des record c'est peut-être ça
il faut dire que vous êtes bien parti en
tout cas ce 493 confirme que vous êtes
en totale contradiction avec vos
déclarations et vos engagements vous
nous parlez euh d'écoute des oppositions
de bienveillance de coconstruction mais
on attend toujours hein on a plutôt des
passages en force un refus du débat
parlementaire et un dénis démocratique
le temps passe et vous ne changez pas de
méthode il se trouve qu'il y a un an euh
j'étais à cette même place et vous
madame la Première ministre à cette même
place également nous étions dans
l'hémicycle pour débattre et oui d'une
motion de censure déposée dans le cadre
du PLFSS alors alors je les relu mon
intervention pas le PLFSS 2022 et bien
je vais vous redire les mêmes choses
mais en condensé comme ça on va gagner
un petit peu de temps Marine Le Pen et
le groupe rassemblement national vous
mettez il y a un an en garde sur la
véracité des comptes de la CQ il y
avaittu à ce sujet et c'est important
des recommandations de la Cour des
comptes Marine Le Pen et le
rassemblement national parlent de
projection approximativ sur les années à
venir alors un an plus tard c'est la
même chose le déficit va se creuser sans
voler parallèlement le taux de
prélèvement obligatoire est toujours en
France le plus élevé d'Europe les
Français charchent avec une loupe les
baisses d'impôts et de taxes en résumé
soit vous avez du mal avec la gestion
des finances publiques soit vous
détruisez volontairement le système de
santé français ou alors en fait c'est un
petit peu les deux à la fois depuis un
an est-ce que question très simple
est-ce que la situation s'est améliorée
pour les Français quelques indices avant
de répondre y a-t-il toujours une
pénurie concernant certains médicaments
réponse oui y a-t-il toujours des
déserts médicaux et dans ma
circonscription c'est pas des déserts
d'ailleurs c'est une tra médicale la
réponse est oui la durée d'attente aux
urgences est-elle réduite réponse non le
personnel des hôpitaux publics est-il
épanoui réponse non les professionnels
libéraux vous applaudissent-il réponse
non alors il y a quand même une ligne
budgétaire qui ne souffre pas c'est
celle de l'ame pour une bonne prise en
charge médicale ah j'attendais vous avez
été long à réagir là pour une bonne
prise en charge médicale il vaut mieux
être clandestin en France que Français
vivant en France vous savez ceux qui
travaillent payent leurs cotisations des
impôt mais qui ont Infiné moins
d'avantage selon un récent rapport
sénatorial vous l'avez peut-être lu hein
ce budget ame dans sa forme actuelle
connaîtra une forte augmentation dans
les années à venir alors je relisais euh
cet après-midi les conditions
d'obtention de me hein c'est sur le site
servicepublic.fr il faut que la personne
en situation irrégulière donc hors la
loi remplisse un dossier et a le déposer
dans une caisse primaire de l'assurance
maladie mais enfin quand on y réfléchit
c'est complètement uvesque on demande à
une personne hors la loi de déposer un
document officiel dans un service
administratif français alors il y a une
question d'ailleurs que se passe-t-il si
cette personne se fait contrôler par la
police à ce moment-là on peut quand même
se poser la question alors si vous
voulez lutter vraiment contre les
clandestins et donc les mafias qui se
nourrissent de cette situation vous
savez où allez procéder à des contrôles
d'identité bon on va revenir au PLFSS en
recourant au 493 vous avez supprimé
l'amendement de nos séndateurs
rassemblement national qui avait été
adopté par le Sénat pour mémoire cet
amendement permettait aux employeurs et
indépendants ultramarins de conclure
avec les organismes de recouvrement des
plans d'appurement de leur dettes de
cotisation et contribution sociale en
recourant au 493 vous avez également
réintroduit les dispositions prévoyant
une contribution de l'agir Arco au titre
de la solidarité financière du système
de retraite contre et c'est ce qui est à
noter l' viis des partenaires sociaux
alors ça fa avouz que c'est quand même
incroyable vous arrivez même à abîmer un
système qui fonctionne la gestion par le
patronat et par les syndicats de cette
de laagirk Arco ils sont sont unis pour
vous dire non non comme ces Français qui
ne veulent pas d'unossible doublement de
la franchise médicale être malade n'est
pins à choix en septembre il y a eu un
sondage ifob vous l'avez peut-être vu
qui nous apprenait que 37 % des Français
avaient déjà renoncé à une prise en
charge médicale alors qu'ils en avaient
besoin il y aura encore tant de choses à
dire sur votre manière de conduire la
politique du pays à coup de 493 mais
nous allons avoir le loisir d'y revenir
car visiblement il y a un nouveau 493
qui se profile à l'horizon alors tout
cela vous rappelle que vous n'avez pas
de majorité alors une bonne façon de
prendre ces responsabilités serait de
demander à Emmanuel Macron au président
de la République de procéder à une
dissolution de l'Assemblée nationale
nous nous sommes prêts he en attendant
je vous rappelle la position du groupe
rassemblement national sur cette motion
de censure nous ne la voterons pas je
vous
remercie merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup la parole est à Madame la
première
[Applaudissements]
ministre madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur générale mesdames et
messieurs les députés nous voici donc
réuni en ce dimanche soir pour la
traditionnelle motion de censure déposée
dans les mêmes termes par les mêmes
députés sur les mêmes
textes une motion de censure qui une
fois de plus mobilise parlementaire et
gouvernement dans des débats stériles
plutôt que de consacrer notre énergie
pour répondre au défis concrets que
certains soulèvent à raison et je vous
confirme madame la députée Youssoufa que
je serai prochainement à Mayotte pour
construire des réponses face à des
difficultés que je mesure pleinement et
je le dis à Monsieur le Député d'Arville
la
réindustrialisation et la transition
écologique sont des objectifs que nous
partageons également mais ce soir cette
motion de censure sollicite aussi les
services de l'Assemblée nationale le
dépôt pavlovient de motion de censure
qui n'ont rien d'une obligation
constitutionnelle ni d'un usage
républicain les mobilise le weekend et
parfois jusque tard dans la nuit je veux
les
le profnalisme et leur
disponibilité mesdames et messieurs les
députés la situation est connue de
toutes et tous les Français en ont bien
conscience et la comprennent il nous
faut un budget pour notre sécurité
sociale personne n'en doute aucun groupe
d'opposition ne soit discuter avec le
gouvernement pour le construire c'est
une position revendiquée il n'existe
aucune majorité alternative capable de
gouverner le rejet de 26 motions de
censure depuis 1 an et demi
l'approuvver nous devons donc
conformément à la Constitution recourir
à son article 49 alinéa 3 en revanche ce
que nos concitoyens ne comprennent pas
c'est pourquoi vous vous tentez sans
cesse de censurer les moyens de nos
services publics et aujourd'hui de notre
modèle social pourquoi vous désirez
censurer ce texte et donc une
augmentation de près de 3 milliards
d'euros des moyens pour la santé
pourquoi vous voulez censurer des
mesures pour les travailleurs
indépendants pour les agriculteurs pour
les lycéens de la voie professionnelle
pour lutter contre la fraude ce que
personne ne peut comprendre c'est
pourquoi vous vous obstinez à censurer
ce projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale qui prévoit 640
milliards d'euros pour protéger les
Français qui améliore notre lutte contre
la fraude qui porte des mesures
concrètes pour revaloriser nos soignants
pour l'accueil des jeunes enfants qui
créent 7000 nouvelles solutions
d'accompagnement pour les personnes en
situation de handicap et qui m en place
un service public de repérage précoce du
handicap pour les enfants de moins de 6
ans mesdames et messieurs les députés
sensur ce qui ne trompe personne ce sont
vos contevérités et votre mauvaise fois
vos contrevérités quand vous osez parler
de budget de renoncement ou de texte de
de rigueur alors que les dépenses de
toutes les branches de la sécurité
sociale sont en augmentation votre
mauvaise foi quand certains nous accuse
de ne pas chercher de compromis alors
même que 50 54 textes ont été adoptés
1493 depuis le début de la législature
54 textes sur 58 c'est donc la
quasittalité d'entre eux les choses sont
simple quand les oppositions de l'arc
républicain sont prêtes à travailler et
à construire avec avec nous nous
trouvons des compromis c'est possible
même sur les textes financiers le projet
de loi de finan de fin de gestion l'a
montré ce que chacun voit ce sont les
mensonges et les outrances de la France
insoumise quand vous refusez d'entendre
toute opinion cont contradictoire quand
vous multipliez les injures et les
incidents de séance quand vous bafouez
la présomption d'innocence comme vous
venez encore de le faire ce soir quand
vous piétinez l'unité républicaine à
chaque
et j'ajoute que votre attitude fait des
émules après des mois à feindre la
respectabilité ces derniers temps le
vernis craque au rassemblement national
de plus en plus régulièrement vous aussi
vous faites claquer les pupitres pour
couvrir la voix de l'orateur vous
apostrophez vos opposants et les membres
du gouvernement les extrêmes se
rejoignent cela ne surprend
personne mesdames et messieurs les
députés la sécurité sociale c'est la
solidarité à la française c'est une
partie de notre identité c'est le
fondement de notre pacte social et de la
promesse
républicaine sur ce texte plus encore
que sur les autres j'aurais aimé que les
oppositions saisissent la main que nous
leur tendions j'aurais voulu que nous
puissions nous retrouver sur des mesures
qui rassemblent plutôt que de débattre
d'une anè motion de censure devant un
hémicycle quasiment vide rejeter ce
budget c'est jou à la roulette russe
avec notre sécurité sociale alors de
notre côté nous ne prendrons aucun
risque j'assume de porter un PLFSS qui
augmente les moyens de notre modèle
social j'assume de prendre les décisions
nécessaires pour protéger nos
concitoyens avec la rapporteur général
avec la présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales avec les députés de la
majorité avec mon gouvernement j'assume
de prendre mes responsabilités et d'agir
toujours pour l'intérêt général au
service des Français je merci merci
beaucoup madame la Première ministre la
discussion est close je vais maintenant
mettre au voix la motion de censure
déposée par Madame Mathilde panot et 77
membres de l'Assemblée le scrutin est
annoncé dans l'enceinte de l'Assemblée
nationale je rappelle que seul les
députés favorables à la motion de
censure participent au scrutin et que le
vote se déroule dans les salles voisines
de l'hémicycle le scrutin va être ouvert
pour une durée de 20 minutes il sera
donc clos à
20h53
la séance est
suspendue voici le résultat du scrutin
majorité requise pour l'adoption de la
motion de censure sur la majorité
absolue des membres composant
l'assemblée 289 pour l'adoption
89 la majorité requise n'étant pas
atteinte la motion de censure n'est pas
adoptée en
conséquence en conséquence la deuxème
partie du projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale pour 2024 est
considéré comme adopté en nouvelle
lecture l'ordre du jour appelle la suite
de la discussion en nouvelle lecture du
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour
2024 nous abordons maintenant la 3è
partie du projet de loi concernant les
dispositions relatives aux dépenses pour
l'exercice 2024 et la parole est à
madame la Première
[Musique]
ministre moi je vais prendre le basin
madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur générale mesdames et
messieurs les députés il y a quelques
instants pour la 27e fois en 1 an et
demi vous avez rejeté une motion de
censure contre mon gouvernement
néanmoins et les débats que nous venons
d'avoir l'ont encore montré la situation
n'a pas changé il n'existe pas pas de
volonté de la part des oppositions de
trouver un compromis sur le texte le
temps des débats a a été
considérablement réduit par le dépôt
systématique de motion de censure et
nous avons des délais constitutionnels à
tenir nous avons besoin du projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
pour faire vivre notre modèle social un
projet de loi de progrès un projet de
loi pour nos soignants pour l'autonomie
des personnes âgées pour les familles
qui cherchent des solution d'accueil
pour leurs enfants ou encore pour les
personnes en situation de
handicap projet de loi qui a évolué
grâce à vos amendements et grâce aux
travaux du Sénat je pense notamment à la
question du financement des épades ou
encore au renforcement des droits à la
retraite pour les pour les sapeurs
pompiers professionnels les surveillant
pénitentiaire ou les douaniers nous
avons un devoir d'agir et de protéger
les Français aussi sur le fondement de
l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la Constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement sur la 3è partie et
l'ensemble du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2024 je vous remercie merci beaucoup
madame la Première ministre l'Assemblée
nationale prend acte de l'engagement de
la responsabilité du gouvernement
conformément aux disposition de
l'article 49 aléa 3 de la Constitution
le texte sur lequel la première ministre
engage la responsabilité du gouvernement
sera inséré en annexe au compte-rendu de
la présente séance en application de
l'article 155 5 alinéa 1er du règlement
le débat sur ce texte est immédiatement
suspendu ce texte sera considéré comme
adopté sauf si une motion de sensure
déposé avant demain
20h58 et voter dans les conditions
prévues à l'article 49 de la
Constitution dans l'hypothèse où une
motion de censure serait déposée la
Conférence des Présidents fixera la date
les modalités de sa discussion prochaine
séance demain à 16h débat en salle la
martimee sur le thème le clore d'connes
en Martinique et en Guadeloupe l'action
de l'État face au nécessaire réparation
la séance est
levée